now if you are looking to beat your
kokan tournament player then
congratulations on clicking this video
because if you manage to watch Until the
End not only you are going to equip with
a lifetime surprise weapon against this
opening but along the way I have shown
some cool tricks and traps where if your
opponent fall for it then the game can
be finished very quickly
after E4 and C6 I propose you start with
Knight to F3 whereupon after
D5 rather than going for the popular
options white should continue with
E5 and I must tell you that I'm using
the secret weapon from last one year or
so and this line SES me very well that I
don't have any problems against
caroan personally I think this is one of
the most trickiest response to caroan
where many black players doesn't know
how to
respond for example if you look at the
database these are the four top choices
and amongst them Bishop to G4 and Bishop
to F5 is by far the most popular
choices however you will also learn what
to do against black other
choices so let's start with the black
most popular choice namely Bishop to G4
pinning down the Knight and the black
idea is very obvious he wants to play E6
and C5 a kind of a French structure
where Bishop is outside the pawn
chain okay we are going to respond with
D4 and after E6 we play this crafty move
C3 which looks very Innocent but it has
a crafty idea that the most popular
choice by black
CI actually has been prevented
here how let's check
out well white will take this pawn and
if you think that what's the big deal
black can simply take it back as it is
the top choice for from the black side
well guess what black has fallen for a
first stake and I hope you indeed see
this wonderful chair which actually wins
the peace at just seventh move of the
game so watch out for this one as in
Blitz and bullet many strong players has
fallen for
this okay what about black identify this
threat and continue with Knight to
C6 this time around we can defend our C
Pawn with Bishop to
E3 yet again setting up a nice platform
for our upcoming trick that if your
opponent continue with Knight captures
E5 looks like winning the pawn and
attacking the Knight but unfortunately
the same story after this queen check
two of the black pieces are hanging
and what else Knight to C6 Queen
captures G4 winning the pace but this
time at nth move of the
game so it is pretty clear that black
can't touch of E5 pawn and if he plays
anything else then white has moves such
as Bishop to D4 and B4 which confirms
his advantage of extra Pawn so the
Baseline go goes as follow Bishop takes
F3 Queen takes F3 and now black can take
on E5 with everything looks so cool
right guess what here comes the third
tricky platform and white will kickart
with Bishop to B5 check Black Knight has
to block it whereupon we can pile up the
pressure on this spin Knight with some
very natural moves
C4 obviously black can't take it if he
continue with mooves such as A6 then not
to worry our Bishop can always come back
on A4 and please note there is no B5
available here so that is right out of
the equation black has to defend the
spawn after this yep you guessed it more
pressure with Knight to C3 and there is
a game came in the database where a
black player nearly
2400 continue with Bishop to E7 white
took on
D5 and after both the side Castle on the
king side one simple move Rook to D1 and
black to his horror find out that he can
do absolutely nothing to save this
B so this is one of the high-profile
trick in this line which you definitely
want to watch out in your tournament
practice many of you say that well all
the tactics is based on this weak Bishop
so how about taking this Knight on F3
and then take on C5 isn't black is
clearly better well of course not as
this time around we have this lethal
move Queen to G3 which by force provoke
the move
G6 white should be more than happy if
black continue with move such as king f8
or Bishop f8 which is obviously some are
the bad choices so G6 what
else and there is a famous saying that
when you play G6 you want to put your
Bishop on G7 as if you look at this
position these dark squares are become
extremely weak and the guardian is
playing football match at somewhere
else what I mean to say is there are
severe consequences of this and to point
out the problems I like to show you a
model game of a Grandmaster where white
continue with Knight to
D2 Knight to
C6 Bishop to
D3 Knight to E7
Knight to B3 attacking this bishop
Bishop to
B6 and now you will see why this is such
a big deal as white continue with Bishop
to G5 Black Thought I can play Queen to
C7 getting out of the pin and when white
defend the E Pawn with Bishop to
F6 black wants to play Rook to G8 so
that he wants to Castle on the quein
side
well why shows this is a pretty bad idea
by some accurate moves
A4 A5 Bishop to B5 encouraging black to
Castle on the quein side which in fact
black
did but it turn out as a big
mistake can you see
why the answer is very simple white can
two on C6 and unfortunately for black he
has to take back with the
pawn and after this some very simple
moves Knight to D4 that night is way too
strong so black obliged to take yet
another piece but at the end of the
result if you look at this position
white has a very simple plan namely
Castle on the king side and then become
hell loose on the
seafile where
clearly if you put this position and NH
CH engine it is obviously liking the
wide with a huge
margin